all right pilots we know you've been at
this titanfall business for a few weeks
now and you know a lot about how the
game works you know how to satchel rodeo
and play vortex catchin not to get into
an evac ship when there are three or
more enemy Titans nearby deathtrap but
learning is a lifelong endeavor and hey
there's probably some cool stuff you
haven't tried out yet so we spent some
time messing around with Titan loadouts
and finding sneaky pathways for happy
flanking surprise check them out
with all the nimble ferocity of the
classic DeNiro character and none of the
destructive family life the Raging Bull
is a Titan class for those who like to
bob and weave stick and move
hit and run dine and dash equip a
Strider chassis with the - quick charger
kit and there will be no catching you
you can easily scoot around buildings
zip away from danger or even take long
flanking routes like this one in the
lagoon map heading around this giant
ship usually takes you too far away from
the action but with raging bulls speed
you'll be back in the ring right quick
now let's talk about how to process all
that rage in a healthy productive way
you can always use that speed to get in
close to an enemy Titan into a
straight-up ordnance bark you know the
quad rockets and rocket barrage with a
side of electric smoke to give
everything that nice metallic burning
flavor but that's an easy one and the
Raging Bull is smarter than that you
still start by rushing in and popping
the disorienting electric smoke but you
also fire off a cluster missile just
past your target to punish them if they
retreat then you pop back out and go to
work with the chain gun and extended
mags you may not be able to see your
enemy in smoke but if you keep an eye on
the hit marker every bullet is like a
little radar ping that tells you exactly
where they are if they come charging out
at you punch them back into the smoke
with your big Titan punch and then just
keep hitting them and hitting them until
you shucks that Titan like an oyster
but if you need to take a defensive
stance and control the long sightlines
of a map-like fracture or bone yard suit
up in the lane defender a 40 millimeter
cannon with extended mags and fast auto
loader serves to exert your influence at
a distance and an Atlas chassis with the
core extender increases the likelihood
that you'll land those high damage shots
from downtown equipping the multi target
system can help you track enemy movement
when they're playing it coy with cover
positions and a lock-on shot is a good
way to get them to pop their vortex
shield prematurely speaking of innuendo
remember to always use particle shield
protection this kind of stodgy defensive
Titan class has a tendency to overstay
its welcome on the battlefield so in
case your enemies start playing the long
game too quick your pilot with the
charged rifle get to an elevated spot
and blast away no not at the shabby
looking space dragons shoot the enemy
Titans okay fine take a potshot at one
dragon bard two tops it's not like
you're restoring a diminutive displaced
people to their ancestral home gear or
anything you're basically just killing a
pack of hobo pterodactyls
the charge rifle is great for long-range
Titan toppling and even better when
you're out of danger
the massive vertical corridors of the
rise map are perfect for getting
elevated and you can even run around on
top of the map if you are too squeamish
about seeing a big death clock on the
screen
just fall back into the gap a little bit
double jump out of it and you've got
another 10 seconds to live what could
possibly go wrong
Oh fine you big baby just stick to your
zip lines and use this big drainage pipe
at the end of the map to keep your head
down you big baby
okay look there's still plenty more
Titan weapons to strategic eyes about
but we're gonna round this little vid
out by talking triple threat the
Moneyball class lays down a carpet of
destruction from which no grunt can
escape and it'll lay low any pilots
sloppy enough to try and run up on you
problem is those roly-poly bombs also
damage you so equip the regen booster in
order to lick your self-inflicted wounds
remember you're the spoil sport in this
loadout not directly taking on Titans
when you can help it
but harrying them and working that sweet
area-denial game like sorry not over
here and access deny and seats taken
and employees only sir please turn
around
the minefield upgrade makes you an even
fiercer area denialist and it's a great
way to keep those - coring Striders from
messing with your flag and if someone
gets up in your face while you're
rocking the triple threat
don't risk missing them by sticking with
the horizontal spread shot aim down your
sights and it'll turn your fire spread
vertical so you can deliver that sweet
deadspace damage of course you'd ideally
be reversing away from a fight in order
to lay down your best damage and using
ramps like the long bridge into the
wrecked ship on relic and the sunken
factory area on outpost 207 to let the
splosions just roll on down line alright
that's it get back to titan falling put
some of these ideas into practice and
don't forget to do some exploring most
titanfall maps are bigger than you think
and contain nifty passages like this
tunnel to the Bay on Smuggler's Cove or
the many tricky tricky zip lines on
boneyard
oh and try your luck in the new improved
matchmaking Lobby we've had pretty good
luck getting moved out of matches with
gen8 Rhian Lister's and we're interested
to hear how it goes for you folks thanks
for watching
all units return to HQ terminating this
mission effective immediately
proceed to nearest exact point for
evacuation